[موسيقى]
موسى عسيري يعمل كاختصاص خدمات طبيه طارئه
يمتطي دراجته الهوائيه بمكه لتقديم
الاسعافات الاوليه للمعتمرين والمصلين في
المواقع التي يصعب على مركبات الاسعاف
الوصول اليها الان
استجابه خدمه فيها الهلال الاحمر تسع
سنوات بالنسبه للحالات اللي نباشرها الان
بالدراجه الهوائيه متراوحه ما بين اعياء
اجهاد حراري ثبات بسيطه من الحالات اللي
ما انساها باشرنا حاله
وصلنا الحاج بفندق
كان بيتحدث معانا فجاه
توقف القلب والتنفس عملنا له انعاش قلبي
رياوي والحمد لله يعني عادل النبض والتنفس
في المستشفى استحدثت هيئه الهلال الاحمر
السعودي بموسم العمره فرقات دراجات
الهوائيه في المنطقه المركزيه لضمان سرعه
الوصول الى الحالات الطارئه في اوقات
الذروه اذ يتعامل المسعفون مع خمسين حاله
يوميه هذه الدرجات تعمل بماطور كهربائي
يوفر الوقت والجهد والماطور يعمل بسرعه من
20 الى 30 كيلومتر في الساعه بقوه تحمل
تصل الى 90 كيلو متر الشحن الواحده مجهزه
تجهيز كامل بحيث يقدم لطالب الخدمه
الاسعافيه جميع الخدمات التي يحتاجها وفي
حال احتياجه لسياره اسعاف يتم دعمهم
بسياره الاسعاف في ابقاء الفرقه لحال اصول
عمره منظومه صحيه كبرى عملت عليها الجهه
المعنيه في السعوديه بموسم
العمره في ظل ازدياد الاعداد الملحوظ
للمعتمرين والمصلين والذي يصل الى اكثر من
مليون ومئتين الف زائري يوميا للحرم المكي
من مكه المكرمه سلطان السلمي العربيه
[موسيقى]